so i'm going to start off with a super
easy question for you
who shot jack that is um
a multi-layered question it uh
uh actually funny enough on set none of
us knew
originally uh we're all very uh
no one none of the casts knew there was
a ton of bets going on
there's actual bets on set as to who
who had done it and no one knew and
um it shocked everyone actually the uh
the answer no
no one thought uh no one actually knew i
i'm
i'm so i'm so like spoiler worried i'm
like
oh my god yeah yeah it was crazy you
posted on
social media you know you thought season
two was dramatic
wait for all the twists and turns in
season three so
how much fun is it being on a show like
that oh it's amazing it's
like uh it's great being on something
that gets
try and top itself all the time like you
know
every character gets just like
everything just sucks a little more from
season to season and it's awesome you
know it's it's a lot of fun being like
oh in season one they had trivial
problems and then season three like
they're trying to find like
the guy who almost killed someone and
then who is it and what are they doing
and they're
it's it's so much fun it's it's it's
just like good uh
uh good crazy fun to watch and and be
in so i love it you know when you first
signed on for season one of this series
did you have
any idea that it would turn into one of
the most popular shows on netflix
no no a pretty short answer
uh i i really i really didn't know
i mean when i got cast for originally i
knew that it was a book series but i
didn't know that it was
so popular because i never heard of the
show before i
i didn't know anyone not only like of
the original age group but like all
these other things and
and then being on the show i had a bunch
of people being like oh man this is
gonna be like a huge show and i was like
and we'll see you know i think i think
it's i think it's gonna do good but i
don't think it's gonna be like
you know like the daredevils or like
part of like
you know spoken in the same same uh
sentences like the crown or something
like that
and i um i i was quite surprised seeing
seeing how well it did i mean i'm like
extraordinarily happy i was just like
i was like whoa this is insane i never
thought it would get this
this big and uh and yeah
yeah there are die hard fans even i know
my producer alyssa right now
like we can't wait for season three like
when the trailer dropped everybody was
like yes
you know it's coming um what was so
great about season two is that we
definitely got to see a lot more of
ricky we got to see ricky uh
essentially you know be in love with
lizzie
uh taking it to the next level how much
are we gonna see that relationship
evolve in season three uh you're gonna
see it evolve a lot
you know it's gonna go through its ups
and downs and
its twists and turns a lot and uh
i was very very happy with it it felt
very
realistic to a real relationship and um
and i think it was it was very well done
uh
yeah it's one of those things where you
you don't know how much you can say
and how much you can elaborate yeah yeah
okay well let me ask you this do you
think liz is a good influence on rick
um i think in season two she was
definitely
a bad influence but i think
she's not necessarily like a bad person
and her influence
isn't uh isn't bad
it's just different is what i kind of
realized is that
oh everyone's just like everyone always
talks about how lizzy was this
is this horrible influence on ricky and
for a while i agreed
but in retrospect i see it more like
she's just different and everyone always
knows ricky in this one way and now that
he's like
now that he's talking about himself in a
different way and acting different
everyone just sees it as a bad thing
doesn't necessarily mean it's a bad
thing right
okay so yeah i like that yeah
okay well you can't see more of that in
season three um
you know this show has just such a i
don't know there's something so
heartwarming about it it puts people in
such a good
place it's a feel-good show what's the
vibe like on set
um it's very relaxed very playful
um yeah the best the best times on set
is where um you have alex and martin on
set
and they're they're just joking around
constantly
uh they're always um
they're always doing like their first
few takes are like kind of like
um funny takes their joke takes where
they uh they'll go through the whole
scene and then at the end they'll
they'll throw a random curveball at you
and you're not exactly sure
um what it's going to be yeah and
sometimes it'll just be going off script
completely and
and just trying to like have a fun time
and it's it's just
it's hilarious i like that i mean
every scene is so beautiful like it
makes you
want to live there what's it like for
you shooting in vancouver um
it's beautiful it's so scenic um some of
the shots where you see like the outside
outside like jack's bar and stuff
it's um just gorgeous and i'd never been
there before and
um you know like i always knew bc is
like a beautiful place but
you know when you live in the city all
the time you don't really necessarily
see it
and then when you're going out to like
you know far out places
like you know into like squamish and and
farther
you're you're seeing all these beautiful
landscapes that you just didn't know
exist
yeah and yeah it's crazy some of the
cool places that you see this stuff so
yeah i feel like that's like a huge
draw for the show too like people just
kind of want to escape there and go to
the small town it's so beautiful
um what can you tease us
about the relationship between mel and
jack
in season three obviously you can't say
a lot everyone can't get enough of them
uh-huh oh yeah what as a fan as a fan of
the show
what what can you tease us about what we
can expect
um
um i think one thing that
i can kind of tease is that it's going
to be
there's less of the um typical
because i they got to they got to show
me a little bit and it was nice to watch
it
and yeah no it was very cool it was very
nice of them
and uh
one thing that i really appreciated
about the show that i think the fans
will appreciate
is there's a lot of movies and tv where
it's like this whole
you know the whole show is based on this
will they won't they
yeah and i think one thing that you're
going to see is you're going to see less
of this will they won't they
and more of this they will but how will
they do this
and how will they do how will they
handle this relationship
after two seasons of like like hemming
and hawing
and uh yeah no it's it's cool
i think i think the fans will enjoy that
more time to see them as a couple
instead of time seeing them trying to
like figure it out so that's what that's
what i think they're going to like the
most
there's going to be a lot of uh a lot of
a lot of relationship in this season so
they're going to like it
yay hey that was good teas you did good
that was great thank you thank you
you little beads of sweat and you're
like how do i say it without spoiling
anything yeah
i know especially when you're working on
such a popular show do you have
uh family and friends who are as
obsessed as like everybody else in the
world and do they ask you
for spoilers yeah yeah a lot of them
um you know i got you got the cousins
and you got the
the family and friends who you who don't
talk to very often who are all the sun
are texting and being like oh my god and
you have an idiot and i'm like i really
can't tell you
i would love to but i really can't tell
you and uh
yeah actually uh my uh my step-grandma
she's like she
she was the one who actually told me
that these books were popular and
constantly asked me these things so i
have to be careful i can't
i can't tell my dad very many spoilers
because if i tell my dad
it's kind of like telling my my grandma
too so i gotta be very careful so yeah
there's so many
so many funny things that you gotta be
careful about now so
i love that okay well last question
hopefully this won't be too difficult
if you had to sum up season three using
only three words
what would they be um
uh here we here we go let's think um
maybe like
watch me just uh struggle over here um
i left the hardest one to laugh i'm so
[ __ ] yeah no the whole interview has
been great don't worry
everyone's just seeing everyone's just
seeing like smoke come out of my ears
um
you can use one word you can use one
word one word don't worry
okay no no it's okay it's okay um i'm
just gonna use two words cause i'm lazy
um very very dramatic
i suppose yeah it's pretty dramatic this
season i think it's
more dramatic than the other seasons for
sure uh in different ways
but yeah that's that's my that's more
than three words but that's what i was
uh that's that's kind of my
thoughts on it you know it's it's very
dramatic in the season it's uh
it's always about taking it to the next
level i think that's kind of that's kind
of how the show likes to
likes to live and how the shoulders uh
like to like to do it
so yeah yeah oh i love that well
congratulations on all the success on
this show
obviously you know people cannot wait
for season three and yeah i can't wait
to see it
okay fantastic well i can't wait for
everyone to see it too and you know
hopefully they all like it so
you